no what did he say he's going to destroy
the world I don't want to be preached
yet wait strike that I don't want to be
preciate while trying to enjoy a piece
of entertainment it's unseemly but that
doesn't mean I don't want religious
undertones it's just rare to find a
story that welcomes those who don't care
about religious matters yet avoids
offending people who have a personal
stake in it well it's a great time for
religious entertainment Noah debuted at
number one of the box office as I play
final fantasy 10 HD for the first time
there are a surprising number of
similarities to the story of that famous
art it's given me new appreciation for
our popular entertainment can broach
such complicated issues no business man
corrupted disclose who fitted for finals
so he must be destroyed Noah tells a
story of one the Creator cleanse the
earth of the heathens running a muck
it's certainly a subject that could
alienate those who don't conform to the
moral beliefs that no holds the guy's a
vegetarian after all and meat is
delicious but the movie of voids
evangelizing or portraying Noah as a
paragon of virtue I'm in a world of
sinners so I can relate to him easier
than if he's without flaws which made
the dilemma he faced more compelling the
Noah movie boiled down one of the oldest
stories ever told into a tense family
drama it's entertainment that uses its
religious message to further the plot
instead of forcing such ideas down my
throat
and then there's Final Fantasy 10 in
both didn't Noah a moral under current
runs through society and those who
aren't aligned with those beliefs are
considered evil machines are the
downfall here people turn their backs on
nature in a vengeful being from the
ocean caused massive destruction to
punish the offenders and like Noah
there's hope yoona is the savior of
Spira I must find a way to help the
innocent people of the world granted no
one you and achieve this in very
different ways but the overarching ideas
are very similar it's not just the basic
plot points to bowl stories share either
it's the way they're told that really
resonated with me the characters are so
earnest in their beliefs that I
understood their feelings I hope I hope
I did okay there's no irony here no
wings do they have some crazy ideas that
must be mocked nothing of that sort it's
real and genuine we question the
characters when they make poor choices
because they're imperfect so even though
we see the world through the eyes of
saviors I still felt as if they were my
equal crafting such relatable characters
is the key to what makes these religious
stories so grounded their struggles are
so honest that I could imagine myself in
their shoes even though their stakes are
so much higher than what I face in my
life and that's the best way for me to
accept the messages being told no one
final fantasy 10 aren't trying to
convert anyone they're trying to show a
flawed we all are and that there is
always a solution there is one key
difference between Noah and final
fantasy 10 Noah lays bare it's religious
themes there's no doubt what the source
material is and its greatest achievement
is how it so willingly embraces those
with different beliefs Final Fantasy 10
doesn't do that it hides through a layer
of abstraction so that it's biblical
connection is not readily appearance
it's impressive how a mainstream game
could successfully tread ground that's
still considered taboo but i'd love to
see another step forward the industry is
ready for blockbuster games that are
openly religious they've reached
our plane by now but no to use next time
yes religion can be a scary subject but
if it's handled in a frank and honest
way no one has to feel excluded or
offended hey not bad